Die stichprobenbasierte Quanten-Diagonalisierungsmethode, kurz SQD, ist ein quanten-klassischer Hybridalgorithmus wie Krylov-
Quanten-Diagonalisierung KQD, wie VQE und viele andere. Bei der Verwendung solcher Hybrid-
algorithmen kann es hilfreich sein, darüber nachzudenken, wo jeder Algorithmus Quanten- und klassisches Computing nutzt. Denk daran, dass VQE Zustände auf einem Quanten-
circuit mithilfe klassisch optimierter Parameter erzeugt. In diesem Fall befindet sich der Zustand selbst auf einem Quantencomputer. Obwohl
das Erreichen des Zielzustands ein Prozess ist, der sowohl klassisches als auch Quantencomputing kombiniert.
Der Erwartungswert des Operators wird durch Quantenmessungen berechnet.
Aber auch eine klassische Kombination von Termen ist notwendig.
Im Gegensatz dazu nutzt SQD einen Quantencomputer, um einen nützlichen Unterraum zu erzeugen, auf den der Hamiltonoperator oder ein anderer Operator projiziert werden kann.
Der Hamiltonoperator wird dann vollständig klassisch diagonalisiert, um den Zielzustand zu finden. Angenommen, wir haben ein
wissenschaftlich oder industriell relevantes Problem, das als Eigenwert-Lösungsproblem auf einer Matrix mit n Zeilen und
n Spalten formuliert werden kann. Angenommen, n ist so groß, dass eine exakte klassische Diagonalisierung keine Option ist. Es
wäre eindeutig vorteilhaft, die Dimensionen unserer Matrix zu reduzieren und dabei alle relevanten Eigenschaften des Grundzustands zu erhalten. Tatsächlich ist das das
Ziel vieler näherungsweiser Eigenwert-Lösungsansätze, einschließlich klassischer Krylov-Methoden. Nehmen wir an, dass wir genug über unser Problem wissen, um eine
vernünftig gute Schätzung der Form des Grundzustands zu machen, aber nicht genug, um das Problem direkt zu lösen. In diesem
Fall könnten wir viele Messungen unserer guten Näherung des Zielgrundzustands durchführen. Die Ergebnisse dieser
Messungen liefern uns einen Unterraum von Rechenbasiszuständen, der alle relevanten Komponenten unseres
Grundzustands enthält. Die Projektion auf diesen Unterraum würde eine kleinere Matrix ergeben, die die relevanten Freiheitsgrade
dennoch enthält. Der Arbeitsablauf dafür ist wie folgt: Du beginnst damit, einen guten
Ansatz zu wählen. Genauer gesagt: Wähle einen Ansatz, dessen Träger mit dem des Zielzustands übereinstimmt. Wir werden genau besprechen, was
das bedeutet. Als Nächstes misst du den Zustand in der Rechenbasis, wie es mit dem Sampler-Primitiv gemacht wird.
Dann verwendest du die Sampling-Ergebnisse, um einen Unterraum zu definieren, der den Grundzustand enthält.
Dann projizierst du deine Matrix auf diesen Unterraum. Schließlich diagonalisierst du die kleinere projizierte Matrix klassisch.
Lass uns jeden dieser Schritte einzeln betrachten, wobei wir besonders auf die Definition des Unterraums achten.
In der gesamten Quantencomputing-Welt ist die Wahl eines guten Ansatzes immer entscheidend. Im Fall von SQD bestimmt deine Wahl des Ansatzes,
welche Rechenbasiszustände beim Sampling gemessen werden können.
Der wahre Grundzustand kann als Superposition einer Teilmenge von Rechenbasiszuständen ausgedrückt werden. Diese Teilmenge
wird als Träger des Grundzustands bezeichnet. Um eine gute Schätzung deines Grundzustands und seiner Energie zu erhalten, muss dein Ansatz
eine von null verschiedene Projektion auf die Rechenbasiszustände im Träger des Grundzustands haben.
Dieses Diagramm stellt den Raum dar, der von allen möglichen Zuständen auf der Anzahl der verwendeten qubits aufgespannt wird. Wir möchten einen
Ansatz mit einem Träger, der den Träger des wahren Grundzustands enthält.
Betrachte ein sehr kleines Beispielsystem mit einem Grundzustand s_Grundzustand = 8 *
Zustand 1 0 0 plus 6 * Zustand 0 0 1.
Dessen Träger besteht aus diesen zwei Vektoren 1 0 0 und 0 0 1. Nehmen wir an, der Ansatz hat die Form Ansatz 1 ist A mal
Zustand 1 0 0 plus B * Zustand 0 1 0 plus C * Zustand 0 0 1. Sein
Träger ist also die Menge der drei Vektoren 1 0 0, 0 1 0 und 0 0 1, eine Obermenge des
Trägers des Grundzustands. Das ist ein guter Ansatz.
Stell dir nun vor, wir hätten stattdessen einen Ansatz der Form Ansatz 2 = a * den
Zustand 1 1 0 plus b * den Zustand 0 1 1 gewählt.
Dessen Träger besteht aus diesen zwei Vektoren 1 1 0 und 0 1 1, der keine Überschneidung mit dem Träger des Grundzustands
hat. Das ist ein schlechter Ansatz.
Beachte, dass der Ansatz nicht unbedingt eine gute Näherung des Grundzustands sein muss. Der Ansatz könnte
einen viel größeren Träger haben, oder die Koeffizienten könnten im Ansatz und im wahren Grundzustand sehr verschieden sein und trotzdem gut funktionieren.
In dieser Phase haben wir einen gut motivierten Ansatz verwendet, damit der Quantencomputer einen Zustand ähnlich unserem Zielzustand annimmt.
Hier dargestellt ist der unitäre gekoppelte Cluster-Ansatz UCJ, der in der Quantenchemie sehr nützlich ist.
Wir wollen jetzt den Zustand des Systems messen und Bitstrings erhalten, die den kollabierten Zustand jedes
qubit beschreiben. Denk daran, dass die Hamiltonoperator-Schätzung wie in VQE viele Quantenmessungen erfordert. Das liegt zum Teil daran,
die Unsicherheit zu reduzieren, und zum Teil an der Anzahl der Gruppen kommutierender Pauli-Operatoren, die den Hamiltonoperator zusammensetzen.
Bei Sampling-Methoden benötigst du immer noch viele Messungen, aber aus anderen Gründen. Jetzt brauchen wir viele Messungen, um effektiv die
vielen Rechenbasiszustände zu sampeln, die in stark verschränkten Quantenzuständen beteiligt sind. In SQD entsprechen die gesampelten Bitstrings
Konfigurationen des simulierten Systems. Wenn das untersuchte System absoluten Einschränkungen unterliegt wie
Erhaltungssätzen in der Physik oder Chemie, dann werden die meisten gemessenen Zustände gültig sein. Aber einige gesampelte
Bitstrings entsprechen aufgrund von Rauschen und Fehlern ungültigen oder nicht-physikalischen Konfigurationen. Ein Prozess namens
Konfigurationswiederherstellung zielt darauf ab, diese verrauschten Samples in eine Menge genauerer Konfigurationen zu verfeinern.
Dieser Prozess beinhaltet die Erzeugung neuer Konfigurationen durch probabilistisches Kippen einzelner Bits basierend auf
gemittelten Orbitalbesetzungen und bekannten Teilchenzahlen.
Die verfeinerten Konfigurationen werden dann verwendet, um Unterräume für die Hamiltonoperator-Projektion und Diagonalisierung aufzuspannen,
wodurch die Treue der Quantenzustandsdarstellung iterativ verbessert wird.
Schauen wir uns ein trivial kleines Beispiel der Konfigurationswiederherstellung an, um ihre Bedeutung zu verstehen. Angenommen, wir messen ein
Quantensystem mit vier qubits, die vier Molekülorbitale repräsentieren, und erhalten die folgenden Bitstrings vom
Quantenprozessor. Jeder Bitstring repräsentiert die Besetzung eines Orbitals. Eine 1 für
besetzt, eine 0 für unbesetzt. Qiskit verwendet eine Notation, bei der das am wenigsten signifikante qubit ganz rechts steht.
Zum Beispiel zeigt 1 0 1 0 an, dass die Orbitale 1 und 3 besetzt sind. Diese
Messungen wurden nur aus pädagogischen Gründen gewählt. Die resultierenden Besetzungszahlen entsprechen möglicherweise nicht einem physikalischen System. In physikalischen Kontexten ist es
oft der Fall, dass das System eine bekannte Gesamtzahl von Teilchen hat. Es kann auch andere Erhaltungssätze geben, die
du nutzen kannst, um die Physikalität eines gemessenen Zustands zu bestimmen. Um konkret zu bleiben, nehmen wir an, unser System ist
bekannt dafür, eine Gesamtteilchenzahl von n=2 zu haben. Das sagt uns die Gesamtzahl der Einsen, die in unserem Zustandslabel
erscheinen sollten, was als Hamming-Gewichtsbeschränkung bezeichnet wird.
Einige gemessene Konfigurationen verletzen jedoch diese Beschränkung. Der Zustand 1 0 1 0 ist physikalisch gültig. Aber der Zustand 1 1
1 0 hat zu viele Teilchen und der Zustand mit lauter Nullen hat zu wenige Teilchen. Null
tatsächlich. Diese Verletzungen können auf Rauschen im System oder Messfehler zurückzuführen sein. Wir brauchen eine Möglichkeit, zurückzukehren
zu Konfigurationen, die physikalisch sinnvoll sind, zumindest näherungsweise.
Das wird als Konfigurationswiederherstellung bezeichnet.
Um unsere verrauschten Stichproben zu korrigieren, kippen wir probabilistisch Bits in ungültigen Konfigurationen, basierend auf der durchschnittlichen
Orbitalbesetzung, gemittelt über gültige Konfigurationen.
Orbitalbesetzungen sind die Erwartungswerte des Anzahloperators, der auf jedes Orbital wirkt. Diese werden geschätzt und
selbstkonsistent verfeinert, mithilfe der aus SQD erzeugten Zustände. Schauen wir uns zum Beispiel Orbital 2 an. Bei zwei der
vier gültigen Konfigurationen war Orbital 2 besetzt. Das ergibt eine erwartete Besetzung von 0,5.
Wir machen dasselbe für die anderen drei Orbitale. Jetzt kehren wir zu einer ungültigen Konfiguration 1 1 0 zurück. Wir können eines der
Bits von 1 auf null kippen, um eine gültige Konfiguration zu erzeugen. Aber welches sollten wir kippen? Eine Möglichkeit zu entscheiden ist
die Abweichung der Besetzung jedes Orbitals von den Durchschnittswerten, die wir gerade berechnet haben.
Hier sehen wir, dass der größte Unterschied in der Besetzung von Orbital 1 liegt. Wir könnten also erwarten, dass Bit 1
von einer Eins auf eine Null gekippt werden sollte. Natürlich liegt Orbital 2 nicht weit dahinter. Und es ist immer möglich, wenn auch unwahrscheinlich, dass
dieser gemessene Zustand das Ergebnis mehrerer Fehler im selben Zustand ist.
Nur die größte Abweichung vom Mittelwert für alle ungültigen Zustände zu wählen, ist nicht optimal. Stattdessen werden Bits
probabilistisch gekippt, wobei die Wahrscheinlichkeit eine Funktion der hier gezeigten Differenzen ist. Angenommen, in diesem
Fall ändern wir das Bit, das am stärksten von der durchschnittlichen Besetzung abweicht. Also wird aus 1 1 0 dann 1 1 0 0. Dasselbe würden wir für die
andere ungültige Auswahl tun. Sagen wir, in diesem Fall kippen wir Bits 1 und 3.
Nach diesem Korrekturprozess haben wir einen neuen Satz von Konfigurationen, der vielleicht so aussieht.
Mithilfe dieses verfeinerten Satzes können wir die durchschnittliche Orbitalbesetzung aktualisieren, um die Genauigkeit zu verbessern. In unserem Fall sind die neuen
Besetzungen diese hier.
Dieser iterative Wiederherstellungsprozess stellt sicher, dass verrauschte Messungen in physikalisch sinnvolle
Konfigurationen gefiltert werden, was die Genauigkeit der Eigenzustandsannäherungen in SQD verbessert. Das SQD-Qiskit-Add-on hat einige Werkzeuge, die
dabei hilfreich sein werden. Wenn wir gute Arbeit geleistet haben, die Zustände im Träger des wahren Grundzustands zu sampeln,
sollten wir in der Lage sein, nur die Teile des Hamiltonians zu betrachten, die auf diesen Unterraum wirken,
und trotzdem einen guten Grundzustand und eine gute Energie zu erhalten. In unserem trivial kleinen 4-qubit-Beispiel gibt es anfänglich 2 hoch 4 oder 16
mögliche Zustände des Systems. Durch eine Kombination aus Sampling und Konfigurationswiederherstellung reduzieren wir dies
auf drei Zustände in unserem Unterraum von Interesse. Drei Zustände, von denen wir hoffen, dass sie den Träger des wahren Grundzustands bilden.
Wir projizieren jetzt unseren vollständigen Hamiltonian auf diesen Unterraum. Das heißt, wir bilden eine Matrix M aus einer Spalte von Vektoren aus unserem
wiederhergestellten gesampelten Unterraum und eine analoge Matrix M-Adjungierte aus den Zeilen, und wir multiplizieren M-Adjungierte H M
bildlich. Das bedeutet, die Matrixelemente in den Zeilen und Spalten zu nehmen, die den Zuständen in unserem
wiederhergestellten gesampelten Unterraum entsprechen. Die hervorgehobenen Zeilen und Spalten sind jene, die unserem Unterraum entsprechen. Und die
dunkler hervorgehobenen Felder, wo sie sich überschneiden, sind die Elemente, die wir für unsere neue projizierte Matrix behalten.
Jetzt, da wir den Unterraum von Interesse ausgewählt haben, können wir diese Matrix auf einem klassischen Computer
mit einem Standardlöser diagonalisieren. Wenn der wahre Grundzustand vollständig aus Zuständen in unserem Unterraum besteht, sollte diese
Diagonalisierung den richtigen Grundzustand und die richtige Grundzustandsenergie liefern. Wenn wir lediglich den größten Teil des Grundzustandsträgers haben,
kommen wir möglicherweise nahe heran. Sobald wir den Grundzustand für diesen projizierten Hamiltonian erhalten haben, haben wir einen sehr
nützlichen Zustand, aus dem wir die durchschnittliche Besetzung jedes Orbitals berechnen können.
Früher wurden unsere Besetzungen aus Zuständen berechnet, die wir mit einem Ansatz gesampelt haben, von dem wir hofften, er würde uns helfen,
uns unserem Grundzustand zu nähern. Es gab aber keine Garantie, dass die durchschnittliche Besetzung jedes Orbitals aus diesem Sampling der Besetzung
im Zustand niedrigster Energie entsprach. Lass uns zurückgehen. Wir hatten eine Stichprobe von Rechenzuständen. Wir haben die Konfigurationswiederherstellung verwendet,
um alle physikalisch ungültigen zu korrigieren. Dann haben wir die durchschnittliche Orbitalbesetzung mit allen von ihnen berechnet. Der
Grundzustand enthält möglicherweise nur einige davon. Der Grundzustand dieses projizierten Hamiltonians ist vielleicht nicht der wahre Grundzustand
unseres ursprünglichen Systems, aber er ist der Zustand niedrigster Energie, der mit einer beliebigen Superposition der
wiederhergestellten Zustände in unserem Unterraum erzeugt werden kann. Die Orbitalbesetzung dieses Zustands ergibt eine Energie kleiner oder gleich
der Energie der Besetzung aus dem wiederhergestellten Raum. Diese Besetzung ist also eine bessere Schätzung unserer
Grundzustandsbesetzung. Wir können den Konfigurationswiederherstellungsprozess mit dieser neuen Besetzung wiederholen und können das
iterieren, bis unsere Konvergenzkriterien erfüllt sind. Sample-basierte Quantendiagonalisierung ist schnell im Vergleich zu
anderen Algorithmen der nahen Ära wie VQE. Sie ist skalierbarer und robust gegenüber Rauschen und Fehlern beim Sampling. Es
erfordert jedoch immer noch, dass wir einen guten Ansatz vorbereiten, mit einer großen Projektion unter den Träger des wahren Grundzustands unseres Systems. Wenn überhaupt nichts bekannt ist
über unseren wahren Grundzustand, muss SQD möglicherweise in Verbindung mit anderen Methoden verwendet werden, um zunächst etwas über den
Grundzustand zu lernen und sich iterativ anzunähern.
SQD spielt eine entscheidende Rolle in der aufkommenden Suite klassisch-quantenhybrider Algorithmen und ist einer der
wichtigsten Treiber hin zu nützlichem Quantencomputing.